das heißt der geothermal generell talbot
aus dem normalen generator und irgend
welchen zusatz die teams das soll ja
erst mal brauche ich allgemein hier
dieses branding popstar womit sich die
teile dann auch wieder abbauen können
genau das ist am 5 ich kann mir meine
schenken und oskar nicht gut gab schon
eine elektrische grange und die ist
jetzt schon nicht mehr so eine
haltbarkeit die von mir hier aber gesagt
nach soll jetzt der jüngst nicht wieder
dass ich mir hier alles einfach schenken
lassen sondern ich wäre auch selber 10
rabatt rietz gelaufen aber wenn hier
andere mitspieler natürlich zum letzten
mal sachen schenken wenn es dann einfach
am ende der aufnahme meinte hey kopiert
danke dass du aufgenommen was hier
diamanten und so klar
dann kann ich natürlich nicht einfach so
das ist ja gut freundschaft dient zum
einen erhält von uns alle gegenseitig
wir haben ja mehr oder weniger keinen
streit jetzt hier so untereinander also
streit allgemeine ich habe halt im spiel
so dass wir so pvp technisch ist der
allgemeine innerstadt alles erlaubt
außerhalb könnten uns alle gegenseitig
umbringen soll ich mal was bringt uns
das dann hat bei denen umgebracht hat
man vielleicht ein paar items aber dann
sicher nicht zu bauen wo zu bauen ja da
bin ich jetzt gerade bei ich wollte mir
das gefühl dass noch mehr aufgebaut wird
ist das ja ein gesamt erstmal den sander
weggehauen und wollte jetzt links und
warte noch mehr auf erledigt ob alles
seine zeit
ergreifend ein standort mit einem tag so
ich wollte erst mal was essen aber die
fremden computer punkte also da erstmal
danke anto wieder sehr viele sachen per
email gesendet hat gerne mehr e-mails
davon dass er ist sehr nett so jetzt mit
besonderen adressen oder nähe also
einfach kräfte google meldet kommen nur
ich habe jetzt die persönlichen
nachrichten die privaten nachrichten
habe ich auf youtube jetzt deaktiviert
weil der nicht so viel bullshit einfach
ankommt das hat denen er ja auch schon
jetzt seit längerem gemacht wenn man
mich einfach normal erreichen will
sondern das land rover oder e-mail
müssen
layer aus wenn du das paket mit dem
laser ab so und wir haben noch jemanden
nachricht geschrieben damit sogar den
namen vergessen damit aber letztens
schon mal gesagt dass er das sehr gut
gemacht hat also bei tobi war das erste
level i nachricht bestehen damit zu über
themen mit so fett geschrieben dann
ärzte krabbler dazu dann versuchen dann
werkzeuge blabla nicht am nachricht wäre
das ein echter nachrichten die kriegt
man echt selten auf häufen sich solche
machen wer dann noch jemand geschrieben
dass ich erstmal ärzten alles mit dem
soll am besten sind einfach tim kopra
saphire kohle eisen lied hab ich jetzt
noch gar nicht gehört lässt sich gar
nicht ja deswegen hab ich davon habe ich
gleich sex und ich habe mir noch nicht
einmal verbaut
also ihn gar nicht brauchen die
atomkraft im kings ergattern
ich glaube schon dass genau wie hier
diese etwas tut also du siehst der berg
ist schon komplett abgetragen das geht
echt verdammt zügig traten bergauf
er hat mir dann auch noch geschrieben
dass man rupert riess züchten soll da
bin ich auch gerade dabei
und man soll mit dem tri top einmal
richtig auf die rubber nasen machen als
auch die so rangendinger und dann das
verbrennen bzw
gerade mein extractor tun ist genau wer
dann muss das auch nicht mehr verbinden
das heißt du sparst du sogar die energie
das zu verbrennen oder die kohle
dementsprechend je nachdem was zu nutzt
und kriegt halt dreimal so viel aus ach
so und wenn du diese lasen freunde hast
du kannst zwar zweimal drauf drücken
aber ich würde dir nur empfehlen nur
einmal so auszudrücken dann bleibt dann
nämlich so ein hohles loch und das fühlt
sich dann wieder auf ok du kannst also
wenn das ganze hier erstmal zugewachsen
ist dann sich das schon besser aus
also dann ist das auf jeden fall schon
mal ein bisschen besser leben würden wir
sagen jetzt habe ich echt scheiße gebaut
also was hab ich hier angeht ich zum
vorjahr wo man die ganzen berg hinab
frage was willst du darauf machen gerne
mit wolltest du begann im mai dann so
ein zweier werke wie ich das hier
gemacht habe so dass das von wegen auch
noch passt ist stimmig ist der etwa kurz
der screenshot grad von den blümchen
bienen zeugs gemacht das blut so schön
irgendwie sowas was brauche ich denn
jetzt also erstmal dank an die
nachrichten die immer wenn ihr tipps hat
wenn ihr wirklich in der menge tipps
habt dann können wir das per email
schreiben und zu kleinere sachen dass
die zweite person gemacht hat wie was
ich mitnehmen sollte das könnte auch
einfach ein konto schreiben genauso wie
man es eigentlich keine tipps geben
doch doch als ich bekomm tatsächlich
auch noch tipps vor allem ganz am anfang
war das ja schau dir mal folgende
tutorials an oder so oder da haben wir
ganz ganz viele leute was geschrieben
essen wirklich so viele tipps wieder
reinkommen das heißt die leute sind auch
wirklich feuer und flamme für das
projekt hat das vor allem das geile ist
ja wir haben ja nicht nur eine mod drauf
also park hat jetzt mit tatkraft
angefangen mit dem zaubern und alles
heft dann er mitglied robbie ist er
somit normalen minecraft oder so aber
man kriegt echt man hat in jedem in
jeder mord hat also ein paar experten
sage ich mal bei den zuschauern die dann
sich mit einzelnen mods auskennen wenn
ihr eigentlich jetzt schon sagen muss in
frack und ich haben festgestellt dass
wir vielleicht in das ins gespräch
bringen sollten ob wir auf ultimate
upgraden
aus dem grund weil na ja ich sag mal so
stark ist jetzt schon so ziemlich durch
wenn ich jetzt meine bienen und
zauberten habe
dauert nicht lange dann bin ich auch
komplett durch mit dem ganzen fisting
egal ich fange gerade erst an
also ich meine bank hat ja auch schon
achtmal soviel folgen wie ich
aufgenommen
er hat glaube ich auch schon zwanzig
oder dreißig und vierzig sagen ich bin
jetzt hier hat nicht nicht 20 30 15
minuten sondern auch 30 minuten papst
dabei aber mir tendiert auch neuerdings
leider dazu also das ist leider für user
die freuen sich dass es zwischen 30
minuten einer stunde ist es bei mir kann
ich das einfach nicht machen wir im
internet
da wird dann ab laut weil er 30 minuten
folge wird bei mir glaube ich fünf
stunden dauern
von daher wird das nicht möglich sein
bei mir deswegen kommt weiterhin 15
minuten ist auch völlig akzeptabel ich
meine akzeptabel das ist mehr als in
ordnung
ich habe kann man dieses komische das
ist das was eigentlich darstellt dieses
ein grundstück was wirklich am anfang an
bord haben einfach keiner drauf wohnt 1
oder sollte er die schenkel
sowas ist leute jetzt frank f du baust
außerhalb eines grundstückes ja das ist
richtig aber ich kann vor minuten lag
damit das meine ich mach ja nichts den
anderen grundstücken ich mache das ja
nur damit ich meinen sound anständig
setzt dass man sich nämlich auch schon
die ganze zeit ich mache das sie einfach
so ein bisschen ebene damit einfach
besser aussieht weil ich komme aus
meinem grundstück raus und sie einfach
nur durchlöcherte scheiße hier
von daher habe ich mich da jetzt einfach
mal wenn ihr alle löcher als großzügig
gestopft wie das ist fantastisch da wird
endlich wieder ein bisschen was zu
machen und ich habe schon überlegt was
meine ich werde mir glaube ich eine
hütte bauen
jetzt wo ich das alles hier so berg
technisch praktisch perfekt auf
aufgesetzt habe zwei kinder hast du hier
können wir das ja so lassen das ist
denke ich kein problem so ich schaut
erst mal kurz major wie das technisch
aussieht zwei pflastersteine brauche ich
ich benutze hier nicht den meinigen
laser ich würde zu entspannte musik
electronics zwecke braucht
voll stelle zu kriegen brauche ich
eigentlich nur beverley konzert abbauen
oder richtig kann sich aber auch gerne
meinen kisten betrieben du willst hast
du da holstein gab so viele feuerstein
und ich meine meinung turtles bin
mittlerweile mutter wollte dass
letztlich ein beispiel dafür jetzt nicht
mehr kann sondern captain blood hat sehr
ruhig
du brauchst zu drei stück mit angeblich
mal 3 bei meinem ipad ich möchte jetzt
auch kein angeleitet hat sich noch
keiner darüber beschwert aber einfach
nur so damit dass es dann nicht
losgetreten
danke ich nehme einfach 4 bei dir aus
losser hier 15 abgeschlossen drei
hingeworfen
die glocken ein inventar das 1 5 die
meinte die hat wirklich die kommt hoch
und winkel einfach so 20.6 er damit und
dann irgendwie noch so kleine dinge an
ärzten oder so wenn du irgendwas braucht
kann sich auch einfach fragen ich denke
ich werde jetzt auch gleich bei 45
minuten erstmals machen weil ich hatte
ja letztes das problem auch mit stürzt
der pc ab also einfach nur einen kleinen
sicherheitsrat mache ich dann so dass 45
minuten aber erst in 20 minuten jahr
sagen so jetzt brauche ich nur noch ein
elektronik circus war das heißt nur noch
schnell
für dich zeigt so hier sieht der zaun
schönes da fehlt noch etwas
runde schlafen gehen ja gerne mal mit
meinem hund ja nicht gecheckt
der zyklus der bienchen ist so die
sterbenden irgendwann und am produkte
reproduzieren die sich und die können
auch mutieren oder je nach welcher
generation man sich befindet sich
verbessern
was haben wir hier weil die gibt es das
wollte ich haben weil die prinzessin
schon waldhonig das kann ich hier
anbieten basiert das macht was war die
schuldigen die königin die ist ja
offensichtlich nicht geeignet auf
europacup brauchen und philipp lingg ich
hoffe das funktioniert dann das kann
warum wenden denn zwei leute aufnehmen
und weiter durcheinander
da war hat man denke ich
das haben wir jetzt hier liegende
prinzessin world habitat gemacht aber
ich kann mich jetzt hier diese
körperteile risiko des pächters
extractor hast du extractor die ich
nutzen darf oder die woche arbeiten
überhaupt das richtige machen ich sag
mal so das kostet ich am anfang sehr
viel energie und ich hab gerade wirklich
in überschuss muss man einfach sagen
hatte ich damals die chinesen rein und
dann kriege ich denke ganz von mir aus
auch den wächterrat und so benutzt dann
siehst du mal wohin du hin arbeitest
rollen immer einfach alles erzählt was
du hast mir also alle und was wenn man
irgendwo alten kann
ach so nimmt natürlich nur mit halbem
ohr weil die kartoffeln sicher ja genau
kannst ja auch leichter bei mir
einschmelzen man sieht mal wie schnell
das geht und ich habe ehrlich gesagt
muss ich sagen ich bin nicht ganz
zufrieden jetzt die mit bayer sieht
schon besser aus wenn das so ist aber
nur bis 32 grad langsam was verzaubern
aber es dürfen wir als bank machen
musste man bei soll dass das verlangen
die wirklich die zuschauer meinten das
beste aber dann ging es bergab passage
dann sowas
wo ist denn hier ist das hier das ist
inspektor expect ob als traktorist
langsam weil das noch der basic ist der
muss sich noch im zum advents machen wir
da auch richtig schnell geht das
vertrauen scheint in ohu ahrain gelernt
das ist tenor kann sie gar nicht ein tun
dass die cousinen oder sieht wir jetzt
also genau tenor kannst du oben rein tun
in den remakes rater ganz oben film rain
man sich mal schnell das gibt und was
ist wenn ich dann noch ein wort zu tun
leider ist das offensichtlich bald wie
das ist noch nicht ganz gefixt
wer sollte wieder auf funktionierende
ofens schmelz zwei gleichzeitig auch so
schnell oder noch etwas schneller
du kannst ja mal die 32 rausnehmen und
unten rein tun und dann kannst du ja
dann aufteilen in die beiden spots ist
nur wie schnell das geht alter dass es
nicht einmal auf in die beiden slots von
17 schnell es geht das ist jetzt
unterschied zwischen induction freundes
und elektrik first electric hoeneß ist
der sowie dieser extrakte sozusagen also
genau so langsam wie ein normaler fan
ist aber läuft darauf energie alter sehr
ist jetzt so dass die brauchen
durchgängig energie wenn die keine
energie haben gehen die glaube ich
kaputt
deswegen glaubt ja so ein mega kraftwerk
weil die dürfen niemals ohne energie
sein
das heißt wir haben auch das heißt ich
brauche aus norwegen windkraftwerk oder
sowas weil nur mit kohlekraft hat er
dann wohl nicht so gut also auf lange
sicht nicht nein
serena baute garten atomkraftwerk so wie
ich hörte das geht nicht nur nicht mit
226 ähnlichen müssen ich weiß nicht also
ich weiß was davon halten soll das
atomkraftwerk
wenn er da etwas falsch macht explodiert
ja alles ganz genau und deswegen wollte
ich selber am anfang eines bauern
arbeiten die arbeiten also ich weiss
nicht ehrlich gesagt wie ich mir die
komplette energie erzeugen soll damit
ich die sachen immer haben kann weil ich
habe bisher nur sagen wir kicken
generator
jeder anfang ist klein am anfang scheint
ist wirklich so als wenn man nicht voran
kommt aber glaubt mir du kriegst das
sind ja aber ich weiß nicht wie ich mir
die energie zusammen was immer du hast
wasserkraftwerks park hat man nicht so
führen die richtung macht der bisher nur
generator muss gucken
ich glaube ich einige möglichkeiten
überlegt mal besser zu machen könntest
ja einen aus lava energie gewinnen
beispielsweise auf stimmt da war ja bald
aufgebraucht
durch das wasserkraftwerk hass der
unendlich energie oder genau wasser ist
das einzige ist einzige kraftwerk
sozusagen das zwar am ws bringt wirklich
am wenigsten und zwar deutlich am
wenigsten aber es hält unendlich und das
ist halt der vorher ich habe einfach
nicht ganz so lang machen solar hält
auch unendlich im solarium macht das ist
aber mit sonne das geht nur bei tag oder
ja weil dadurch eine blackbox hast spare
ich jetzt das ja ab das heißt du musst
du so viel produzieren dass deine
maschine tags und nachts laufen können
aber jetzt weiß ich was binary tree
maker passiert und so kann zwei
verschiedene sexo bereit tun ja also ich
habe jetzt gerade tenor und kopper
ordnen und die
machen dass da jetzt ich weiß nicht
genau was ich hier mache ich
terraforming blicke ich meine ganze
landschaft ich erstmal so dass wir
überall gras wächst er wieso kriegt den
kopf hat das duo bronze das auskoffern
raus und die beiden kann ich jetzt auch
zusammen da rein tun indem in taktischen
foul des klimakillers induction
fördertopf herausbekommen wo aus ich
hatte bronze in gold oder und da kam
compper und so was anderes wollten
kopper und tanja bronze ist dienstags
ist ja gemischt aus zinn und job ja gut
wo sehen also den kannst du zusammen
kraft ist wahrscheinlich
aufeinandertreffen sowas habe ich hier
eine bienenwabe ich habe schon so viele
stacks steine hier bin ich top 20 30
steaks oder so achso meinem einige titel
die müsst ihr ganz nach unten kommen
wenn du willst dir das mal reinziehen
ja ich mache jetzt meine ganzen erst mal
fertig unternehmen für mich vorsicht
stufe wie gesagt hier eine seite geht es
runter und eines alarms oder ist ja noch
bis märz war was hat meine meinung
turtle jetzt hier zu lande getan
wie tief das ist was denn da warte ich
komme gleich mal gucken damit zinner
bauer geht das nicht ich hinüber aber
das kann man nicht immer alles von einer
anderen mutter her gut sagt ja ich hab
mich gleich mal was hast du mir gebracht
tenor silber eisenerz war und so viel